hess's law states that the overall
change in enthalpy for a chemical
reaction is equal to the sum of the
enthalpy changes for each step
and this is independent of the path
taken so it doesn't matter what set of
reactions you use if you add up those
reactions and they equal the reaction
that you're trying to find you can also
sum the enthalpies to find the enthalpy
change for the reaction
as an example let's say we're trying to
find the change in enthalpy for the
reaction of carbon with hydrogen gas to
form c2h2 which is acetylene
we can calculate the change in enthalpy
for the formation of acetylene using
these three reactions below
our approach will involve looking at
these three reactions and comparing them
to the original reaction to see if we
need to change anything
for example if we look at reaction one
there's one mole of acetylene on the
left side of the equation and if we
compare that to the original reaction
there's one mole of acetylene on the
right side of the equation so we need to
reverse equation one to make it look
more like our original reaction
to save time i've gone ahead and
reversed equation one so you can see i
did that down here looking at the
original equation for equation one here
were the products and now we've made
those products the reactants
and what were the reactants over here
for equation one have now become the
products
the change in enthalpy for equation one
is negative
1299.6 kilojoules per mole of reaction
kilojoules per mole of reaction just
means how the reaction is written in the
balanced equation and since we've
reversed equation one we also need to
reverse the sign for delta h so instead
of this being a negative instead of this
being a negative we're going to go ahead
and change this into a positive
and also let's go ahead and cross out
the first equation so we don't con so we
don't get confused
next we look at equation two and we
compare it to our original for equation
two there's one mole of solid carbon on
the left side and looking at our
original reaction there's two there's
two moles of carbon on the left side so
to get equation two to look like our
original equation we need to multiply
everything through by a factor of two so
we're going to multiply every everything
in equation two by a factor of two
to save some time i've gone ahead and
written out what we would get we would
get two carbons plus two o2s goes to two
co2
the change in the enthalpy for the
formation of one mole of co2 was
negative
393.5 kilojoules per mole of reaction
but now we're forming two moles of co2
and since we multiplied the equation
through by a factor of two we also need
to multiply the change in enthalpy by a
factor of two as well and also let's go
ahead and cross out
this first version here because now
we're forming two moles of co2
next we look at equation three and we
can see there's one mole of hydrogen gas
on the left side of the equation which
matches the original reaction which also
has one mole of hydrogen gas on the left
side so we don't need to do anything to
equation three and since we're not doing
anything to the equation we're also not
going to do anything to the change in
the enthalpy so it's going to stay
negative 285.8 kilojoules per mole of
reaction
next we add up all of our reactants and
products so we have two co2 plus h2o
plus 2c plus 2o2
plus h2 plus one half o2 so those are
all written down here for our reactants
and then for the products let me just
change colors here we have c2h2 plus
five o2
plus 2co2
plus h2o and so those are written over
here
for the products
next we see what we can cancel out
there's two co2s in the left side and
there's two co2s on the right side so
those cancel out there's one water on
the left and one water on the right and
there's two o2s plus one half o2 which
is 2.5 o2s or five halves o2s so the
oxygens cancel out on both sides as well
and we can see we're left with two
carbons plus
one hydrogen goes to form one c2h2
which is the same as our original
equation
since we were able to add up our
equations and get the overall equation
according to hess's law we should also
be able to add the changes in enthalpies
for these steps to get the change in the
enthalpy for the overall reaction
if we look at the changes in enthalpy
for the individual steps we had positive
1299.6
for the first equation and so that's up
here for the second equation we had
negative 393.5
times two which is negative 787 and for
our third equation we had negative 285.8
so that's negative 285.8 when we add
everything together we get positive
226.8 kilojoules per mole of reaction
so for the formation of one mole of
acetylene from two moles of carbon and
one mole of hydrogen the change in
enthalpy for this reaction is equal to
positive
226.8 kilojoules per mole of reaction